you seem calmer than I expected you be I
got you something
let me open it for you you have to go to
Washington I told you I'm turning it
down I was being selfish you put your
whole life on hold for me the very least
I can do is try to return the favor
are you sure about this we can make it
work
I'll go visit you then you come visit me
and then I go visit you again and then
we make out in the Lincoln Bedroom and
the Jefferson Memorial and the Supreme
Court gallery we'll do it all over
Washington thank you
where did you get a Washington Monument
figurine at midnight on a Tuesday from
my office I have like 50 of them right
the recounts over they just called the
race my god it's still 21 votes but you
won
you won Leslie he won by 21 votes it's
confirmed it's over
you won that was really sneaky and no I
couldn't resist hello Jacob
ah hey what are you doing here why
aren't you out looking for the belt you
and I both know the belt never left the
precinct I don't know that nobody knows
that I kept thinking how did anyone swap
my key and then it hit me
they didn't they swap the safe one of
the hand mades I'm assuming fake Charles
took my safe and then of Amy deposited a
look-alike what did you get fake Charles
so he'd help you nothing in fact he gave
me something the power of financial
freedom I invested in a pyramid scheme
it's no time to go into it right now
okay so while we all tried to figure out
who had the real key fake Charles broke
into the safe remove the tracker and led
Terry in the whole squad on a wild goose
chase my only question is which box is
the belt in well good luck figuring it
out because the clock is ticking talking
it's that one
no that does pattern on top doesn't
match its neighbors you see Jake I'm
always gonna be one step ahead of you
you've lost the ability to surprise me
you're just plain boring again we are
take on a very loving relationship and
it's midnight so I guess I'm an amazing
human slash genius yeah although you
might want to read the inscription on
that there bill why oh no what does it
say Amy Santiago will you marry me
surprised I'm so confused I don't know
what's happening right now I'm so
confused I don't know what's happening
right now title your sex tape oh my god
I'm shaking I'm definitely gonna cry
title your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist and
this is part of the heist I will dump
you so hard no please Ames like it's
really happening okay it's not part of
the heist I promise this is you are I
love how beautiful you are
I love your face and I love your but I
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on I love how much you
pretend to like die hard I like the
second one you don't have to
yeah you're kind and you're funny and
you're the best person I know and the
best detective also for reals I love
your butt I love yours too you gross
Amy Santiago will you marry me Jake
Peralta I will marry you
thank you so much hey circo's this
little [ __ ] escaped so that I teach did
you just mm-hmm
did you say mm-hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
come she well
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to Mary and Maxwell Dwyer and
April Roberta
legend I guess I kind of hate most
things but I never really seemed to hate
you so I want to spend the rest of my
life with you
is that cool is it my turn
April you are the most awesome person I
have ever known in my entire life I vow
to protect you from danger I don't care
if I have to fight an Ultimate Fighter
or a bear or him your mom I would take
him down I'm getting mad right now even
thinking about it telling you
I want to spend the rest of my life
every minute with you and I'm the
luckiest man in the galaxy you left then
a month later you took Terry with you
yeah well we needed a mindless factotum
and he's the best there is a man then
you took a burl I didn't want her to go
as she had become one of my closest
workplace acquaintances but your offer
was too good to pass up so I didn't try
to stop her and Tom left to run his
business Donald left to run hers one day
I looked up I just didn't recognize
anyone so I made a decision an
unthinkable decision
hey well my my my do my eyes deceive me
is that Ron Swanson hello Leslie hello
April
Larry its Terry now okay as luck would
happen oh did you talk to Randy about
the vote tell the Northeast that we need
to put pressure on them or else we're
gonna be waiting forever and I'm tired
of waiting on them okay sorry this is a
crazy day so what's up with you you big
lug nothing important just thought you
might want to have lunch tomorrow
I would love to it's been too long JJ's
diner 12:30 excellent see you then okay
so Randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in Washington
to prep oh my god really
okay against the first flight out of
here and grab the Missouri files meet me
at my car
hey babe I gotta go to Washington can
you pick up the kids oh oh no Ron I
stood you up for lunch you did yes
I waited for a while but it was pretty
easy to figure out what had happened
your life seemed pretty hectic is that
the rest of the story that I stood you
up you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch Ron
you were going I was gonna ask you for a
job in the federal government just
saying it out loud feels dirty at least
once a year I like to bring in some of
my Kevin's
famous chili the trick is to undercook
the onions everybody is going to get to
know each other in the pot I'm serious
about this stuff
I'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole Tomatoes i toast my own
ancho chiles it's a recipe passed down
from Malone's for generations it's
probably the thing I do best
keep an eye on her all right okay will
do
hey hey how's it going good
especially after I took all your money
in Pokemon yeah
hey about when you want to give me more
your money did you undo that now we can
go inside feeling kind of tonight I was
just um
I'm not with you
what I'm really sorry if that's weird
for you to hear but I need you to hear
it
probably not good timing I know that I
just what are you doing
could he expect me to say to that
I'm just need you to know once
well I
I
I can't
yeah
you have no idea London
what your friendship needs to be I don't
want to do that I want to be more than
that I can't
I'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my phone
another fault
I'm sorry I misinterpreted our
friendship
you